in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Justin
and Nicole are with us
hi guys Merry Christmas Merry Christmas
Dave welcome to Nashville where you guys
from
we are from Roanoke Virginia fun and
here to do your debt-free scream
absolutely and how much have you paid
off we've paid off a hundred thousand
dollars in 25 months days love it making
what kind of money during that time well
we started at a hundred thousand and we
took a little bit of a pay cut of about
fifteen thousand but we're now back up
to that hundred thousand Oh Dave I want
to tell you the reason that we're back
up to that hundred thousand is because
this man right here knows how to work
and he took Justin as a police officer
and he took every single overtime slot
and everything every single extra
assignment that he could get Wow to make
up that difference Wow
so why did the income drop well um when
we got married we were living in two
different cities Oh and it was very
difficult for me to find a job where
Justin was in Roanoke and I take a pay
cut to get in the same city as newlyweds
yeah well the thing is Dave we had so
much debt that I couldn't move there
without a job mm-hmm and so it took me a
year to find a job for the first year of
marriage we were apart geez and once I
found a job we were able to move and yes
we did take the pay cut at that at that
point but yeah I I just was kind of like
well that's gonna be $15,000 it'll just
kind of layer a debt snowball and Justin
looked at me and said no it's not he
stepped up and made the day if you'll
stay in the town with me I'll work yeah
it's good right I love it very cool what
kind of debt was the hundred thousand
well the hundred thousand dollars was
100% my Virginia Tech debt Oh VTech all
right very cool so we're gonna get to
play you guys at Bristol I absolutely
that we're still coming up gonna be big
yeah I'd be huge I got my hat when I was
up at Bristol the other day's got you
tea on one side VTEC on the other battle
at Bristol it's a good hat you know
brings up a lot of comments so that'll
be fun good so a hundred thousand bucks
from VTech and you I guess criminal
justice no I'm actually an International
Studies major
concentrated in business real politics
and policy and the market was not good
in 2011 so I took a job where I could
I'm also a military reservist uh okay so
I had a lot of security and public
safety background due to my military
experience and so law enforcement was
the the clear choice at that point and
don't regret it loved it loved every
minute of it cool very cool
good for you guys so were you married 25
months ago then is that what started the
journey a little bit more we didn't
start our debt free journey until August
of 2013 and we were married in April of
that year okay so what what happened in
August what what flip the switch um you
know so when we got married I had never
been in debt and I had money in the bank
mm-hmm didn't know who you were but was
living very close to the principles and
just saving a lot of my income and once
I realized what it felt like to be in
debt and realized that we could be doing
this for 20 years
mhm I just I couldn't take it and I was
like we have to do something this is not
gonna work yeah
and so we Justin heard smothering when
you're not used to it oh my gosh it is
so true when you say that the borrower
slave to the lender yeah I never knew
what that meant until I was a slave
so you're smothering and you walk in to
Justin and tell me about what happened
well he was already paying off more
uh-huh Pam Morin he wanted to get out
because he had he had been living with
it already because we hadn't been
married I I knew about the debt but it's
just different to know something
intellectually and to know it in your
heart mm-hmm and so once I understood it
in my heart
um I found some of your budgeting forms
on a blog and I had seen you around
church and then Justin was working the
night shift at that point and you're on
at night in Roanoke so he would listen
to you and his in his cruiser and it
just kind of all came together and so we
we did our debt snowball for a year
independently just using the website and
listening to the show and then we
decided to to take a class at a local
church and that really gave us the
momentum that we needed and how you were
married for an entire year for you made
them moved aronia that's correct
that's a tough one the tough part is
actually we got married we had an
awesome honeymoon and then I was back
for two weeks and then I got sent down
to Charleston South Carolina with the
military for ten weeks oh my gosh so the
first ten weeks of our marriage not only
were we in different cities but we had
very very little communication yeah well
good news is if you can do this you can
do anything right that Wow so that the
biggest obstacle sounds like what was
the distance and then the extra work
that you've poured in and so yeah so did
people make fun of you guys question
your sanity is you're doing all these
different things when they see my car
they they did I've got a 1991 Honda
Civic oh yeah with two hundred and
eighty thousand miles on it oh yeah
total hoopty and it is about to be
replaced along with well we've got
another car it's a CRV it's also got
270,000 miles and I do a lot of my free
time when I'm not working I'm working on
the cars yeah you but I've got a couple
of them running hoop tease there man you
got some miles on those Honda absolutely
we're getting every dollar out of them
yeah you did well that's time to move up
in car now that you're good for you guys
well congratulations
how does it feel it feels so good I
can't even I I know you know how it
feels but it just it feels like a relief
well the sacrifice y'all put in is
amazing there's there's three things
that we really really love doing our big
hobbies are to give to travel and to eat
let's go so now we can do a lot for ya
so we actually just got back from
Guatemala last week we were down there
on a missions trip and I was able to
snag Rachel off the elevator before your
last segment and we talked to her a
little bit because we used the smart
money smart kids as I taught a life
skills class to the older boys and it
was a little difficult with the language
barrier but there's a lot of kids down
there that are about to age out and
they've got no idea how to handle any of
their their money so it was real
thankful to to Rachel for the resource
that helped us when we were down there
very neat very fun well congratulations
you two very very
all done you're rock stars man you did
it your heroes you can do this you can
do anything you got it this is so cool
all right Justin and Nicole $100,000
paid off in 25 months making a hundred
down to 85 and then Justin kicks in the
OT gets it back up to a hundred count it
down let's hear a debt free scream three
two one
well done you guys you guys would be so
rich so fast and be able to do so much
not only for yourselves and for your
family but for others
you